warning the following trailer contains
scenes from Transformers Revenge of the
Fallen from the director most likely to
masturbate to an explosion comes two
hours of moving pictures and loud noises
that because it was filmed on a camera
technically qualifies as a movie
Transformers Revenge of the Fallen strap
in for a film that somehow managed to be
much much worse than the original with
more racism what are we gonna do with
this shrimp taco but Cap'n you guys owe
me the truck it in there Mike oh no no
not me more product placement and way
more than you care to know about
transformer Anatomy I am directly below
animus to assemble for a filmmaking
effort so lazy Michael Bay reuses shots
from the first Transformers and shots
you literally just saw earlier in the
movie Soundwave acknowledges pursuer
Decepticons mobilize it is time come on
man in a universe full of Awesome
transforming robot characters prepare to
get not excited as they focus on the
same boring humans from the first movie
their Sam Witwicky who's graduated from
stuttering to derp face
unmanly Megan Fox who once again
combines the looks of a professional
porn star with the acting of an amateur
porn star sorry I'm so sorry about your
eye John Turturro
who found a new low after being peed on
by a transformer in the last movie hold
on what is that those two are me guys
and Sam's parents because if there's one
thing fans never asked for its more time
with Sam's parents I'd do anything for
an A all right ride once again
with a whole team of interchangeable
Autobots as they face off against a team
of even more interchangeable Decepticons
in a series of battles then look like
two junkyards having sex with each other
seriously I have no idea who's fighting
what turn off your brain for a plot that
isn't just bad it straight-up makes no
sense and leaves audiences everywhere
wondering why does the US military
forget it as an anti Decepticon gun into
the last five minutes of the movie why
does the Allspark bring Megatron back to
life if it's what killed him in the
first place if the short brings Megatron
back to life why doesn't Sam use his
short to bring Optimus Prime back to
life when Sam dies why does he go to
transformer ever why not people heaven
why is Sam's roommate in this entire
movie why is Washington DC Smithsonian
Museum in the middle of a desert
since when can Decepticons transform
into human beings and why don't they all
do it and what was she doing at Sam's
College and why does she seduce him
instead of just killing him ah
we've already put more thought into this
and the people who made this movie did
beginning middle and facts details
condense plot talent starring all these
Michael Bay's ohms spinning camera the
military low angle shots of people
getting out of cars listening face wet
hot babe extras a slow-motion helicopter
and boobs
here
loud noises Transformers Revenge of the
Fallen
what I tried to do is I as a director I
try to
ah excuse me I'm sorry I'm sorry now you
know how we felt watching this movie
Mikey my name is Optimus Prime and I
send this message to all of humanity
please subscribe
Autobots transform and roll out
giggle make funny buns banana phone
I am altering the deal pray I don't
alter it any further but I believe Aang
can save the world
I gave her my heart she gave me a pen
can you tell me how to get to Sesame
Street